Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. Three things:
First, I went to Los Angeles a couple days
ago to watch a movie. I don't think I'm allowed to tell you the name of the movie, but I can hint
at it. It comes out on June 6th, it's funny
but then other times it's very very sad,
and I really, really loved it.
So that's exciting and also a huge
relief. I need to change shirts because I match the wall.
All right, that's better. In a totally unrelated
story, everyone should read my book
The Fault in Our Stars before the movie
adaptation comes out on June 6th. Was I
subtle? They said I needed to be subtle.
Secondly, AFC Wimbledon had their first
game as a team sponsored by Nerdfighteria.
Rosianna: I'm an internet kid and I love GIFs and
I love Instagram pictures
and I love YouTube videos, but there's something really quite cool to the physicality of it.
To see those physical boards around a physical
pitch designed by physical Nerdfighters,
some of whom live half a physical world away
from me and from the stadium.
Wimbledon lost the game, but the long arc of
history bends towards justice, so we'll be fine.
And lastly, I get to give away some
money. So Nerdfighters raised more than
860,000 dollars in this year's Project
for Awesome. After we pay to make and ship
Project for Awesome perks, all the remaining
money goes to charities chosen by Nerdfighteria;
and today I get to announce ten
winning charities that each receive 50,000 dollars.
First the Harry Potter Alliance, which fights
inequality and illiteracy and once
worked with Nerdfighteria to send five
airplanes worth of life-saving medical
supplies to Haiti after the earthquake there.
Secondly, This Star Won't Go Out, the
organization set up in memory of Esther
Earl that provides direct support to
families of kids with cancer.
Then there's Not Forgotten; they house, feed,
and educate children in Peru. And fourth
we have Save the Children, which works
around the world to fight poverty and disease.
Fifth, Liberty in North Korea,
which is one of those organizations that
helpfully puts its mission statement in its name.
Sixth, Child's Play, which
provides gaming systems to kids in
children's hospital so that they can beat
me at FIFA. Seventh and eighth, we have two water
charities: The Thirst Project and Water.org
Ninth, we have Partners for
Mental Health, another one of those
organizations that tells you what it does in its name.
And lastly TECHO, which I'm probably
mispronouncing, an organization that
mobilizes young people, including a group
of Nerdfighters in Argentina,
to build houses for people living in
poverty around Latin America.
So Hank, all ten of those organizations will
receive 50,000 dollars a piece
from the Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck.
Now people are probably wondering "what
are they gonna do with the remaining
360,000 dollars, are
they gonna spend it all on pizza and
corn dogs?" Sadly, no.
Some of that's going to go to producing and
shipping, like, the t-shirts and the Women of YouTube
calendar. However, most of it
will be split among ten more winning charities.
They are: To Write Love on Her Arms, The
Office of Letters and Light, The World Food
Project, Feeding America, The Wayne Foundation, Pencils for Kids, Women for Women International,
First Book, Kiva.org, and Doctors Without Borders.
So there you have it, the twenty winning
charities from the 2013 Project for Awesome.
Our money's going to go to fight disease
and poverty and illiteracy and injustice,
and I'm so grateful to everyone who
donated and also everyone who took the
time to vote so that we could be good
stewards of this money.
If you want to learn more about these
organizations, there are links in the doobly-doo.
Thank you again for being part of the Project for Awesome with us. As we say in my hometown,
DFTBA. Hank, I'll see you on Friday.